the Final Fantasy 10 10 to HD remaster
is available in two special edition
formats the limited edition and the
collector's edition while all editions
of the game contain the international
version content with over 20 hours of
bonus gameplay never released in north
america both special editions have their
own unique features the limited edition
comes packaged in an art book disc case
and is offered as a free upgrade when
you pre-order the game the collectors
edition which shares its box art the
Japanese version of the remaster is the
ultimate tribute to the artistry of the
Final Fantasy 10 series available
exclusively from the square Enix online
store the collector's edition features a
premium art book package the full-sized
hardbound collector's edition art book
contains 40 pages of exquisite artwork
from the Final Fantasy 10 series and
comes packaged with 5 frameable
lithograph prints of Titus and Yuna the
collector's edition also brings the art
and music the Final Fantasy 10 together
like never before with the Final Fantasy
10 HD remaster original soundtrack
blu-ray disc music this unique
experience includes over six hours of
music set to the game cinematic scenes
concept art and iconic imagery enjoy the
visuals soundtrack on your TV or
download the audio is mp3s when you
pre-order from the square Enix online
store your copy of the collector's
edition will ship early for delivery on
launch day quantities of this exclusive
package are limited so pre-order your
copy today